russian gas firm gas prom is scheduled
to switch off its net its largest
natural gas pipeline running to germany
today citing annual maintenance
the question is if it will switch it
back on
officials in germany and across the eu
are warning utilities and companies to
brace for a possible complete stop to
gas flows
even after the 10-day repair period they
fear russia will use maintenance as a
pretext
moscow has already reduced flows into
germany in recent weeks cutting back
supply to 40 percent of normal levels
again citing repair needs
the north stream stoppage also appears
to be pushing the german government to
undermine its own sanctions regime
against russia
at berlin's request canada has now
temporarily waived its export
restrictions on a gas turbine that the
company siemens was repairing at its
facilities in montreal
delivery and installation of that
turbine which russia says is critical to
restoring gas flows could force the eu
to partially lift its own sanctions on
russia and that in turn has drawn the
ire of ukraine
all right let's take a further look into
this karen piddle leads the efo center
for energy climate and resources she
joins me from munich and my colleague
andrea nepari is joining me here in
studio karen i first want to start with
you we've been anticipating this day
when maintenance begins begins for quite
some time um how alarmed should we be do
we have any idea
i mean we don't know i mean that's
basically it i mean the maintenance is
normal that happens basically every year
10 14 days
the question is really whether there
will be any excuses on the russian side
to actually prolong that period until
when
is anybody's guess
all right one excuse that's been given
to this point for pulling back on gas
imports to germany has been a busted
turbine andre the german government is
now trying to work with canada to get a
turbine in how problematic is this
actually that they're sort of playing i
don't want to say playing along with
that they're actually sort of working on
this turbine in in essence with the
russian government what what can we say
about that well it's a big mess steve
because um what germany had to do was to
convince canada a strong ally to send
back this turbine and to do that they
had to lift sanction temporarily they
say on siemens canada they were
repairing the turbine now they're
sending it back and then the ball is in
the eu's field because we will have to
also lift sanctions probably to let
germany deliver that turbine so germany
is busting its own sanctions in essence
that might be the thing that's gonna
happen because if we want this turbine
to go from germany to gasprom and so to
let them install it on nordstrom one
that's where it should go well we'll
have to lift some sanctions otherwise we
cannot liber really deliver the item to
russia and i mean for germany is a
really big problem we are already here
under strong criticism for what we've
done so far uh for ukraine in terms of
many uh we with uh many uh things that
we haven't been doing enough a lot of
criticism yeah exactly and the problem
is of course ukraine is not amused uh
the the chief of the gas transmission
network of ukraine called is a very very
bad precedent for exemptions from
sanctions and russia is already
weaponizing this for propaganda purposes
is there any guarantee that if the
turbine were in place that supplies
would return to their normal level well
to be honest no because russia could
already deliver more through other
routes right now and so we might also
end up lifting some sanctions so
weakening the sanctions and in the end
they will receive the turbine and not
use it and claim that maybe it's still
broken or whatever they have many
options andre i want to ask you
what kind of efforts have there been on
the german side to find alternative
sources of gas if it's not coming in
from the russian side is germany not
further along than it was
well um we can see that flows already
diminished from russia we went from 55
to 35 percent most of the gas uh the the
the change in the mix of gas uh has been
going towards the netherlands uh belgium
and uh norway especially we're also
trying to build this very big lng
terminal in willem southern it received
the green light recently so it's it's
still a very big struggle and it's not
off the chart or off the page that we
will have to fire up coal plants for
example to actually have more
electricity this winter been a lot of
talk about that a lot of controversy
around firing up coal plants
karen um
we we often talk about this possible
gas stoppage in terms of the economic
and household damage we could see
how can we sum this up for people who
may not really be aware how critical gas
is
in terms of the german economy can you
sort of give us an idea
i mean basically studies at the moment
are predicting that
if the north stream one pipeline and
every other gas from russia would be
stopping right now that we might be
facing uh basically a gap with in
comparison to previous years with
respect to the gas
supply
of about 20 and that is after the lng
terminals the new lng terminals um are
up and running so we would need to uh
reduce our gas demand quite considerably
and that is something that is pretty
unclear so far how far that will be
possible where it will happen
and which to which extent actually
rising prices will play a role here and
how far
actually enterprises or companies can
pass on the higher gas price to
customers
presumably a lot of companies may have
to scale back production if they're
heavily dependent on gas is that fair to
say
that is fair to say i mean some
companies might have the opportunity to
switch for example to oil some might be
able to import things that they would
need for their production that would
have been produced on a on a previous
level with with gas so for example
chemical companies producing and then
reducing that production and imports of
that particular items could come from
somewhere else but there's still a
pretty
um not a very good notion to which
extent that will be possible
all right it's a huge topic that we'll
be following for the coming days that
was karen piddle she leads the efo
center for energy climate and resources
and joins us from munich and andrea
nepari my colleague here in studio thank
you both for joining
us and if you're looking for more on
this topic now you can check out our
youtube special on russia's threat to
cut off european gas supplies
now our reporters go even deeper into
some aspects of the story that we just
heard there from andrea and karen we
also get into other parts you may not be
as familiar with
you can find it on the dw news channel
alongside our other business reports
you